melly-mel Anissa Nonna from Politico
joins us now Melanie good morning to you
good morning the Dow finished down more
than 600 points yesterday is talk
continues of a slowdown both
domestically and globally this tit for
tat continues with China as well over
tariffs how does all this factor into
the g7 today well the president is
heading into this meeting in a very sour
mood as you mentioned his trade war with
China has escalated he's frustrated over
the lack of progress
he's also anxious over these signs that
there could be an economic downturn his
crown jewel is the economy then it's no
secret he doesn't like these types of
global meetings in fact he is sparred
with some of these leaders that he will
come face-to-face with this weekend at
the last g7 summit he didn't even sign
the joint communique which is a
tradition of going back many decades and
so this year they decided not even do
want just an example of how norms have
really changed under Trump maybe he goes
one better by calling for a pullout of
all American businesses I mean just how
realistic is that well it's very unclear
you talk to some Republicans on Capitol
Hill what does the president mean when
he hereby declares companies move back
and no one knows not even in the White
House what he means this is just another
example of the president sort of making
policy by tweet and then his aides
having to sort of scramble on the
backend and come up with something but
you did hear the president come out
yesterday and say we are going to be
tougher on China they up to the trade
war going increased more tariffs but
there is a lot of confusion on Capitol
Hill right now about the direction that
the president is going in that seems to
be some of the norm and even other
things this week with gun control
obviously backing off of what he had
said he used words like chosen one and
referring to himself nobody ever seems
to worry about the base but is there any
point where some of this gets to be too
much for that base even look Republicans
have stood by the president time and
time again through controversy after
controversy but I can tell you the one
area that makes them the most nervous is
the economy so if there is a downturn of
any sort in the economy they might not
be willing to put up with the rhetoric
and the tweets so much his approval
ratings right now are very fragile could
he lose the sum of the Republicans
though over the gun control issue where
they seem to be more on board with the
idea of some changes that is a tricky
issue that political winds have changed
especially in the suburbs where we did
see a revolt against President Trump in
2018 but you have to keep in mind and a
lot of these red and
States gun control is still widely and
popular and there are Republican centers
up for re-election in some of those
states including Mitch McConnell the
Senate Majority Leader former Vice
President Joe Biden raised a few
eyebrows last night at a campaign event
in New Hampshire he's the front-runner
in the Democratic race right now I think
we have this clip let's listen to that
and Bobby Kennedy my senior semester
they're both shot and killed imagine
what would happened if God forbid Barack
Obama had been assassinated after
becoming the de facto nominee what would
have happened in America so you have Joe
Biden talking about what happened if
Barack Obama was assassinated why would
why would one bring that up yeah it's a
good question I'm sure his campaign is
asking the same thing right now
look we knew that Joe Biden one of his
biggest vulnerabilities is that he has
the tendency to stick his foot in his
mouth he's made a couple of gasps
recently including in the Iowa State
Fair when he said poor kids are just as
smart as white kids when he meant to say
wealthy kids and I can tell you there is
a lot of anxiety in the Democratic Party
right now about whether this could hurt
his electability
it gives ammo to President Trump who's
already seized on some of these gaffes
but then there's this other camp of
Democrats who say we can't beat up on
every single little thing for all these
candidates because then whoever does get
the nominee is going to emerge more
damaged in the general election all
right how many Democrats right now in
the next debate we're looking at well
more and more dropping out by the day so
we'll have to wait and see thank you
very much thank you